إذا نظرت إلى مكان وجود العلامة التجارية والمكان الذي
نريد أن نأخذ فيه العلامة التجارية،
فدبي موقع مثالي كما
نعلم جميعًا أنها مركز رائع وبنية
تحتية رائعة نظرنا إلى
مواقع أخرى حول العالم، فهذا
مكان رائع لتوظيف جميع الموظفين.
توجد هنا العديد من البنية التحتية وأنظمة الدعم،
ويبدو أن
الاختيار الصحيح كان صعبًا
مع عملية إعادة الهيكلة هذه التي تم
تنفيذها مع التقسيم الذي تم
وضعه داخل المنظمة وقررنا
نقله إلى دبي في المنطقة نفسها.
نقوم الآن على
أرض الواقع بـ 12 فندق فيرمونت قيد التشغيل في
الشرق الأوسط وحده من بين مجموعة تضم
90 فندقًا على مستوى العالم، لدينا
محفظة قوية هنا علاوة على ذلك، الأمر
المثير للاهتمام للغاية هو أن لدينا
مجموعة رائعة من تسعة فنادق قادمة في
بعض  الوجهات الرئيسية المشتركة أه
مشاريع جيجا في المملكة العربية السعودية لدينا
مشروع رائع قادم في البحر الأحمر
إصدار فيرمونت الرائع قادم على
طريق شاكسيد في سكاي لاين لذا نعم أعني
من منظور خط الأنابيب والنمو،
يبدو الأمر رائعًا هنا
وهو جزء من
جزء  من بين هذه القصص، بما في ذلك رافلز سوفيتيل
ريك صوص وموفنبيك، تمتلك شركة
المملكة القابضة السعودية وهيئة الاستثمار القطرية
حصصًا في الفنادق الأساسية
بنسبة 5.8 بالمائة و10.5 بالمائة
على التوالي وفقًا لمكالمة دعونا
نتحدث عن المملكة العربية السعودية، ما الذي
يجذبك في المملكة العربية السعودية في
هذا؟  المرحلة ستصبح المملكة العربية السعودية واحدة
من أفضل الوجهات ليس فقط للأعمال
التجارية ولكن أيضًا للترفيه على مستوى العالم،
فلديهم الكثير من الأشياء لتقدمها، كما يقومون
أيضًا بإنشاء
بنية تحتية مذهلة في الوجهات الرئيسية بالإضافة إلى ذلك
بالطبع لديهم
سياحة دينية
المدن الدينية الرئيسية في المدينة المنورة ومكة،
يبدو المستقبل رائعًا أريد أن أتحدث
عما شهدناه في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية، حيث شهدنا موجات حارة لا تصدق
خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية والتي
ضربت أوروبا، ومن
الواضح أن هذا كان له تأثير  إن التأثير غير المباشر على
صناعة السياحة له تأثير على
الموردين وما إلى ذلك، كيف
تنظر إلى هذا، هل أنت قلق
كصناعة، لقد تحدثنا كثيرًا عن
البيئة ولكننا تحدثنا كثيرًا
ولم نفعل الكثير، يجب أن أقول ذلك ومرة ​​أخرى
يؤلمني أن أقول ذلك ولكن هذه حقيقة،
ويجب أن أقول إن الصناعة
على مدى السنوات الخمس الماضية حاولت
المضي قدمًا بطريقة إيجابية للغاية
فيما يتعلق بتأثيرها على البيئة،
وتقول إنها استراتيجية مباشرة لتقليل
الانبعاثات  بنسبة 46 في المائة في عام 2030
وتصل إلى ما يقرب من الصفر من الانبعاثات بحلول عام 2050. إن
جوهر الحديث يدور حول هذا
الموضوع وهو مدرج على جدول أعمال الجميع عندما
تنظر إلى موضوعات مثل الزيادة في
درجة الحرارة في مواقع مختلفة وهو أمر
لا يصدق مرة أخرى، وباعتبارنا صناعة
أحتاج حقًا إلى التركيز على هذا الموضوع،
وأعتقد أنه من الرائع رؤية ما تفعله المجموعة الأساسية
ومن الواضح أن فيرمونت تفعله ضمن تلك
البنية التحتية لمحاولة
مكافحة هذا الموقف
[موسيقى]